chat hold on a second's computer
okay for people joining this live stream
this is um
uh one of a series of discussions about
uh
sound and video audio and video
for the upcoming version of language so
where have we got to we were close to
done weren't we
they're very close to them um starting
from up top i wanted to make sure
um about or check with you about the
option name video time range
as a selection option time selection
option you propose that to a
we never got to it we are renaming the
tracks to track selection
are you still okay with video time range
or should it be video time range
selection
why isn't it video time selection
or is it i mean okay wait a minute
this is what we've got is for track
we've got a thing called track selection
is that correct
and it's gonna be specific audio track
selection video track selection
subtitle track selection okay fine so
they're different names
yes
could it just be video time selection
doesn't need to say video time range
selection no i yeah no i think it's
it's okay video time selection is good
okay what track what times time
singular military time yeah times
singular
okay
should we discuss generated data
destination possible or
alternative names i put a couple
suggestions in generated data
destination page
the source page
is this really the right meeting for
that do we have the right people here
unless you want it to go back to lcc
is it in generated as your destination
yes
here's a comment from ethan on a live
stream can people apply image effects to
videos without manually extracting
frames
isn't that what video frame map does yes
okay so like if you want to apply the
same effect to each frame
correct but like for example if i wanted
to have something where i had a
spot that started in the center of the
screen and then expanded on successive
frames how would i do that
that's gonna be coming with um video
map operation or whatever name we're
gonna
call it something that can take time
into account as well
the function could take a slot time into
account
so how would that be analogous to
in the case of time series what's the
analogous operation
moving map but so we have time series
map
but my question is what is moving map
does moving map have
is this does it have a time slot
yeah i think so
yeah does
i see
so that's the kind of the the design
approach to take
for is it obvious that moving map
couldn't just be used on video
yes
because what comes out is a time series
i see
but otherwise the design is similar in
spirit with these
um you know named arguments and so on
that's what we've been often migrating
towards
yes i mean it's an
as if association basically yeah
i think that's very reasonable because i
mean i think them
for video yeah one can imagine all kinds
of things there
okay so that's what's a video frame map
is
map onto individual frames
you killed that function last time i
would like to suggest we keep it around
but yes that's the idea
12 1 has a video frame map you were
suggesting we remove the function
and just work with a video map that
takes
different types of arguments like video
audio
time and so forth
what do you mean
further down in the list we have a
family of processing functions
video map is the current name that you
proposed last time that
that is a video to video the input to
the function f
could be data extracted from video or
your subtitle tracks
and then the output is a video you were
suggesting video frame map could be
merged into video map
but i think as a separate function it is
going to be
useful still wait a minute video frame
map
maps onto each individual frame of the
video right
yes returning a video
yes correct
what is it that returns a non-video
12 1 we had video time
now we have i see so now what we have
here i forgot this i forgot this this is
a good suggestion
video map video map list video map time
series this is the right suggestion
this this is right this is what we want
because otherwise we've got a whole
we spent a long time on this last time
you can keep those three
in addition uh we're suggesting we keep
video frame map and introduce a function
like audio apply
i'm i don't like the name necessarily
those two functions only process one
track the data is
one frame or a chunk of audio so the
func the construction of the function is
gonna be simpler
there is no slot arguments the the
argument is always
known because it's just a frame it's
just boom boom boom image image image
yes so in principle we could have a
video frame map list
although we're not i'm not suggesting it
but we could have that
because this is saying it takes a frame
it it its argument is a pure frame
right but i'm not sure we want multiple
functions i i know that i know that i'm
just
i'm saying but we can't you can't have
video frame map
has to be something that returns a video
correct
right if you want it to return a list
you've got to use video frame map and
then video frame list
on the video yes okay
all right so we were looking at
generated data distribution then we had
some comments on our live stream that i
want to
come to destination no not distribution
i'm sorry i'm i'm my brain is off
somewhere else
i've heard distribution from others as
well
this is a long name um i think going
with persistent
location it might be correct to use
something that has location at the end
storage location was our initial
proposal
and then as we were brainstorming we
were thinking about
possibly thinking about a pair of
options
where one is specifying the input asset
location
one is specifying the output location
okay let me just remind myself what this
is
this is you do a video capture and it's
going to write out a file
where does the file go is that correct
yes
okay um the case that we have right now
with audio capture does what
does some automatic doesn't have the
option
put it um i think has take take the file
argument hello there
is that it is okay and it puts it
under dollar wolfram document directory
slash audio
okay so this is an option that says
where to put this
correct okay
look we're not going to use storage
location we went through that last time
okay it was too general a name
um i mean
i this is the wrong group of people to
have that discussion i'm sorry
we'll bring it back to lcc then maybe
yeah i mean if
it's if you don't like this name i think
that she had a point though
i also think it should be discussed in
lcc so i don't wanna
but there is a point there which is if
we have if everything is location why is
this one not location
it can also be input it's not just
output
okay that's what i'm saying so i think
look sticking with our location business
it might be pretty consistent
sounds reasonable i think that's look i
think it's going to be
and then the dollar whatever it is thing
has to be has to be similarly consistent
exactly yeah i mean why don't you ask
i mean roman and the people who've been
dealing with persistence location
whether they have an idea for this
okay and but but you don't want to put
it in the local object store by default
is that correct we don't
and in lcc we then get to discuss
default locations
i would like to get to that again okay
so reschedule this for lcc okay okay
um comments from our live stream from
net would love it if mathematica could
be a vst
host i don't know what that is connect
and send midi midi events
out to virtual software instruments
i think we will come to that when we
revisit the midi side of things
um because we're mostly dealing with
audio
waveforms and so on right now yeah and
and we
we uh we just went through a couple of
incremental releases where we primarily
focused on
speech and you know everything related
to speech
and and uh right now it's it's video
focused but
the attention is gonna be taken up to
music and then it's gonna
come in there i was gonna ask when that
was gonna happen
by the way i assume that's going to turn
into a new style progress dialogue
yep
well okay um
okay other comments here
okay ethan is saying for scientific
publications we need to have creation of
a grid
paneled window of videos
oh so you mean i think that's video
frameless
i think let's take a look i mean in
other words if we've got let's look at
the video
example
i think what you're going to be finding
video frame lists as an example we have
thumbnail grid example where you
basically
make a collage of some representative
images if i say video frame list of this
i thought i thought it would just do
that with some five or something count
um
okay so image collage of that would
give you some kind of a grid but i think
what ethan is asking is
a collage of a frame to frame collage
creation
of multiple sources and we are going to
be looking at multi-video input
in video map video map list video
no but that's just pretty respectable i
mean this is a very reasonable process
we take a random video
and we make a video frame list in the
image collage that's very nice
yes but i think ethan is asking for
something else
he wants two video feeds or four video
feeds combined into one frame by frame
connected so you have oh i see
oh oh okay yeah
um and how would
i see i see so in other words you're
taking gosh that's an interesting
observation
so someone else was suggesting sandor
was suggesting video assemble
joining videos spatially it's an
interesting operation so right now what
you would have to do is get the
framelits do video color image collage
on every frame
and then do this again is that right but
but the idea is that video map is going
to be able to do that you just feed it
four videos and you specify image
collage as the function that
takes four images frame by frame
extract all frames from the four feeds
and then create a new video
so wait a minute map on a list of four
videos
is going to at every gulp get four
frames is that right
yes okay
so that would just work
okay although i have to say i think if
this is an operation people think
is commonly useful i think it'd be nice
to have a an overall function for it so
you don't have to think through
how the video map thing works i
completely agree
but i would prefer 412 we get the
building blocks and then yeah maybe at a
later stage in the cycle we can
make or design the icing functions yeah
i think video collage is a reasonable
name given that you don't know how many
videos you're going to have right
um okay there's a question of
video position find where a dog shows up
in a video
that's further down in the list you mean
further down
because we haven't done it in the
proposal yes the proposals okay
now what do you think about audio apply
or we can discuss this and then
let's let's discuss this in a minute
sure okay
um
okay let's see brian is a general
purpose mechanism for selecting a
set of frames in a video and then
operating on them
so that's what this time selection video
time selection and so on is about right
is that correct for so no it's it's a
time it's a start and stop time so it's
yes i know but that's what we're talking
about i mean that that's
isn't it if we pick up a video and then
we say we want to operate only on
seconds two through five of this video
isn't that how we do it
yes okay so that's the answer to that
i think
all right because these are free by the
way
i'm sorry what no no those don't work
yet
the uh brian's comment selecting a set
of frames to work on
i wasn't thinking video time selection
should be able to do that
that's why i was oh okay okay fine fine
but
but the time selection is whatever
frames are within those time
that time band exactly
so i think that's what he's asking for
but anyway we can clarify
um the capture functions don't work the
video stream
and video record of a recording stream
works in prototype builds not very
robust
um the capture ones i'm still
i think still can make it to 12 too so
sorry i'm sorry
what did you say was was working and not
working video stream and video record
working prototype builds okay but not
the capture functions
okay plan is saying not just for starts
up time but general function to
select the frame don't we have that
isn't that what the whole video how do
you select a frame for a video i take
this video i want the 20th frame how do
i
how do i get that video extract frame
and then a quantity 20 frames if you
give it just a scalar 20 that's going to
be a frame from 20 at second
but if you say 20 quantity 20 frames
that's going to be the 20th frame
is this function already there or not
yes i mean is it there in 12 1
yes
it's nice
it's just a little weird but that is
says 200 frames
plural and this is all about video
extract frames and yet i'm just
extracting a single frame here
why isn't it video extract frame
singular
oh
you can give it a list and then it gives
you exactly
frames no i understand but but we could
do that
boy a lot changes in one frame i had no
idea
um wow human
you know isn't whatever it is vision
fusion
it's remarkable um okay
and by the way what do i do if i want to
play those frames
list anime or animated image if you have
prototype builds
no but can't you just say video of that
i just want to make those into a video
we are adding video generator obviously
video of that doesn't work why not
we didn't get it implemented um but okay
but i mean
is it a good idea i think in video
generator we are
providing more hooks to specifying frame
rate
and duration and all of that don't care
i think we should just allow video of
that to work with defaults
seems useful just videoify this list of
frames
and then the the only mode of video that
we have is out of core
we are going to be writing to a file
those five six frames
that's live that's okay
that's fine it might not be five or six
it might be three thousand frames
um yeah no it's doable i just think it's
not going to be very useful
if one has to all the time specified
duration and frame rate
or at least one over one is sufficient
no no there should be a default
there should be default there should be
default frame rate
i mean i can imagine somebody has
generated these things having nothing to
do with getting them from video
somebody generating them as graphics and
just wants to turn them into a video
you see what i'm saying in the other
words the path is kind of complicated
right it's a
it's is it animated image what would it
be it would be video of animated image
is that right
yes or video of export of those images
no no but
export is not what i want yeah no video
of animated image would work
yeah but then video of the of the list
of images should surely work
too
why is this not coming up
oh for god's sake
something is very wrong with this
prototype building somebody should
report that
i've noticed these problems before
okay so now what you say is if i take
this
thing here and i say
i don't think video of animated image is
implemented but if you have a video
i just want to animate an image i just
want animated image yep that would work
yep this is going with 24 frames i think
or something it's looping
and also if you want video generator
just pause
and if you do video generator of the
list it also creates a video
um
video generator why do i have to do
video generator
i don't understand what what is video
generator doing here
the advantage to video is that you can
specify what's the duration
which so what why can't you say video
blah blah arrow
duration arrow whatever
because that option is not going to be
useful for other cases where the
where the input is a file
so this became a one second the default
duration here is one second
is that the right thing look again again
okay there's people on livestream are
commenting that instagram for example
only lets you upload videos not animated
gifs
so i mean look video of animated image
should just work
yep that will work okay now the question
of what the default frame rate should be
um i see is
is suggesting commenting iphones
recorded 30 frames per second and 60
what would the default frame rate of the
video function
be what's the answer
so the video generator already resamples
that list
you get something at 24 frames per
second or whatever frame rate
that you specify basically you copy
those frames with
video of frames as i
i still i'm not convinced video of a
list of frames should work
but but anyways if we want it to work
so this is resample so this is this is
just
okay and by the way why did this bring
up a video
player this brought up a remote video
player right it's not playing in
notebook
if you right click on that video gui and
go to switch to either minimal or basic
appearance
this is our in notebook player but it's
not going to be efficient for
higher resolution higher frame rate
until we have library link support
in the front end when is that happening
most probably john says
library link in front end is going to be
a 12-2 feature
but not soon enough for us to have a
video player
in 12-2 what are we doing for the cloud
for the video player in the cloud
we're working with the cloud team on
that it's going slower than
what we want and the issue for the cloud
wasn't the actual player
there are plenty of nice players if you
like you know for them for their for
their web browsers they're just
extremely limited compared to the range
of codecs that we support
which meant that we needed to
support ffmpeg tools and they were
running old operating systems
but that's also changing now so that's
getting easier
so this is by the way there's a stupid
bug which also needs to be reported
which is that the i reported this for
several weeks that in the prototype
build the cursor is wrong
this is still a horizontal i-beam cursor
and it shouldn't be
so you'll support it again okay
so of all this stuff right so in product
any one of these crazy encoders will
work and you're saying on the web
are you going to get all of these to
work or not we are and that's because we
we and that's what's caused the lawful
auto because otherwise
it would hardly very very little would
work by default in the web browser
okay but now all of them will work how
did you achieve that
we transcode oh i see
to what to whatever the browser needs i
forget if that's just one or there's a
is it just mp4 okay so we cut in the
kernel we treated the transcoding
we don't transcode in the kernel ffmpeg
can decode uh all of those
codecs that that were listed in your
notebook
yeah okay we just read them in any codec
their
store okay where were we here
um
let's see i guess down to video position
okay there's a question here
for from ethan what about net encoder
for videos
what's the machine learning team been
doing on that not yet
come coming we yep yeah coming i think
it's it's
next release is going to be the first
one where it can happen
okay ethan is saying need to be more
three and forty
operators on the net neural net
framework
um with 3d nets often working on video
yes i agree um
so hold on a couple of comments here
um ethan's asking so i can cloud publish
a video
the answer is yes right
and then once this report comes yep
um
you can watch mkv what is mkv is that
one of the video formats i don't know
yes
yes we can watch them in our uh
in notebook player but not in many other
video players that are installed on
operating systems by default
okay ethernet is common for export to
gif there is a minimum frame duration
do we know about that and brian is
commenting in default
24 frames per second or 30 frames per
second will be sufficient
what is our default frame rate right now
for video
video doesn't have any default it
whatever
is encoded in the file is the frame rate
that we use
video generator currently used as 24.
but there is an option that i think we
should use 30
i think we should use 30 i think we
should plan for the future i think
otherwise what's going to happen is it's
going to change and people are going to
videos are going to all speed up by some
weird factor
and it's all a bit crazy i i think the
difference between 24 and 30 is not
large in terms of memory size and things
like that but i think we might as well
go with the future as the default
and you know us humans are not getting
upgrade anytime soon
so there's there's a limit to how what
the frame rate that anybody's going to
care about is
actually people care about higher frame
rates to do slo-mo stuff
fair enough but that's on input rather
than on yeah okay fair enough
okay what's next in the in the agenda
here
we wanted to talk about audio apply
and video position video intervals we
didn't finalize the names for those last
time
okay so image position so if i say
in here if i say for example
um the
image position animal
what is that thing anyway it's a llama
i don't know doesn't it have another
name it's a thing that
is in texas what was the name what was
the
do any of us sound texts in here no
but but someone told me someone had an
email correspondent someone pointed out
what the kind of a creature it is
and they're common in texas it's like
great that's the prototype build yeah
alpaca no i don't think it's an alpaca
no it was something else
what is this
oh that's the 12-2 prototype
a guanaco and oryx
my gosh
come on we can just trust the machine
let's see what it says
why is this running so slowly
what is it doing probably needs to load
the whole image net
i know but why isn't it indicating that
it's loading something
um could somebody report that please
yep okay thanks
okay anyway we don't know what this
object is but never mind that
the the concept is that image possession
um what is going on here
something is very wrong let's hope that
we didn't break somehow the image
identification network
had some problems uh in prototype bills
and
some people are out it's august
i know but this is 12 1 yeah what's
going on bad i don't know what happened
unless it's writing data into the same
place
this is bad this is really bad something
is very wrong here
i'll report that
i'm sending something as well okay in
any case
what would this do if it wasn't broken
what would it do image position
of something in here what would it
return
give a position x y position
in the image that the object is
identified or found
okay so there we have two birds
and if it was just one bird it would
still be a double list right yes
that is a very high precision bird
position
absurdly high precision bird position if
i might say so
right right i completely agree we have
this we have
less of an issue in fine faces that we
give
point five positions i think yeah i
would do that yeah around the thing i
was crazy
you know one ten thousandth of a pixel
the bird good luck
you know if it's not if it isn't more
than one pixel it isn't a bird
yes um okay but any case so
so what you're proposing is that video
position
would give the time how would it specify
the times
seconds one in each quantity seconds or
whatever it could be i don't understand
that why why wouldn't
it be i mean video position why wouldn't
it do the audio i mean it's got
3d to specify in right
so it's got it's got the time dimension
and it's got the location
in the video so in principle video
position
could be giving a
you see what i'm saying what kinds of
arguments could video but
i think i think what you're asking for
is video
um map time series of
image position comma video so you want
to find
birds in different frames of the video
video position you can say give me times
for the frames that their mean
brightness is
greater than something i understand so
i'm not sure that video position is the
right name for that
because video you know image position
means
the spatial position of something
position is not
you know uh
what am i looking for here i'm looking
for video position here
you know possession what other functions
do we have in time
series what is our way of do we have an
analogous function for time series
now okay actually that's a part of the
the next pack when we go back to time
series to have
event more event oriented functions
um that find you know zero crossings
or things like that that's quite
important in many cases
all right so what we need is a time you
know is a way
what is it going to return the video
position thing does it return frame
numbers or what does it return
times in
scalar seconds or with units or what i
think
quantities make sense and it could be
either seconds quantity or mixed
quantity with minutes and seconds
what's that lovely thing with a scale
i've never seen one of those before
can we generate those
i mean whatever these graphics are if
these were not generated by purely by
hand things if these were generated
programmatically
you should have a functional repository
entry that does it
okay tim tim is helping us i mean we are
inventing this
as we speak stephen we are the idiom and
so you can see a few prototypes that
will pretty much go down to one or two
models
right i see
how to show what's going on but these
are very beautiful and i mean these
would be very nice
things imagine people putting those in
papers and things that would be really
nice for people
so let's at least have a function
repository entry and later on we can
have some kind of
you know video visualized type thing
that does stuff like this
yeah and i think team already almost has
it we have done it for so many
video functions that last time he said
all of this is being streamlined
i'll i'll tell him to put it yeah okay
okay
okay so now but anyway let's go back
here
so the question is
okay
yeah so you can either request frames
presumably evaluate script
no i don't understand you've got to be
able to say i want frames i want times
back from this
um i think for many other things we we
give some kind of coordinates out okay
in this case time coordinates
that's then the bridge that gives you
basically like a selection to
many other functions like a whole set of
other functions
does it i mean doesn't this give a list
and does that list
as its pair of things is that treated as
an interval in the correct way in other
functions
sorry i i was reading the live stream
chat
um so so what i'm saying is if this
returns a pair
start end position right is that what
you feed to other functions
to um
do you understand what i'm saying is
that what you feed to other functions
to um uh get them to represent
that interval of the video that that
slice of the video so to speak
or does do other functions treat it
listably
it really depends on the function like
video trim
if you give it two two things it's gonna
get get you the whole interval if it's
video extract frames it's going to be
the two frames but that's not what this
function returns either
it returns a list of times where the
event
where the criteria is true so it can be
many more than two
so okay so so it returns the whole dense
selection of those things
yes i think it should have a way of
returning an interval because you
otherwise you're going to end up with
some giant data structure
you know when was the sun out when was
it a daytime
shot oh no that's that's the other
function on the list video intervals
i see and i i really think both are
going to be useful
okay what will be the analog
for intervals in time series right
what's the analog for time series of
both of these things
we don't have that as i said we don't
really have
analysis functions that look at the
value and decide that this is a zero
crossing or this is a
peak crossing or things like that but we
do
need it and
and so we have prototypes of those
obviously but it's going to come
as i said we don't we don't have those
functions right now
with prototypes we have not done the
design and it's not going to make it for
12.2
okay okay so there's more work to be
done
on those to to isolate what are the key
ones needed
you know what's the minimal building
block so what's the key building blocks
to have
right well okay so
okay so video intervals
okay what what bothers me here
you know i could imagine an intervals
function like position
you know you could imagine i've just got
a list of values and i want
all intervals for which
x is you know the value is greater than
zero for example
aggregated so that's a meaningful
function
just for a list it's bothering me video
position is really bothering me it's
it's really confusing me about whether
it's a per frame
crazy as well if i might say so this is
crazy but position
takes a pattern not a criterion
yep right so this is wrong in two
different ways
i often wished we had a thing that did
what positioned us with a criterion
maybe we should
put that in an ild meeting okay that's a
good topic
but um
um
so in a way this is a select function
yes
except it isn't because it doesn't know
it isn't selected because yeah it
returns the indices not the data yeah
right
um
let's see
so that's a question from nicola here
asking whether video resample perform
performs interpolation it does doesn't
it
oh no it will have methods that 12-2
version is going to be
probably very simple nearest resampling
but yes there are very many
algorithms out there proposed for
interpolating frames
okay
for an image position identifying object
what part of the object is the key
from brian that's a good question like
those birds
center of the bounding box okay
um
so i see this is um
um
saying that time should be the default
not frames i think that depends on what
where the video came from um
i think generally speaking we've
you know for audio it became very clear
that it's time that you want
um not sample yes that is
for audio maybe it's true for video as
well i think it's true for video two
when you say time codes you don't say
have you ever heard anybody say look at
this video at frame
2200 and you know 2238. no
my problem is that i'm too old because
yes i do
i do remember those kinds of things
coming up right
oh absolutely but not i mean that was in
you know when when it was very
challenging to process video
right but today we have so much video
right
you know that the youtubes and that's
and especially at very many different
frame rates
referring to time is is kind of going to
be the unifying
axis to work on okay question from brian
is there a function to convert between
lists of frames and times
lists to intervals that's an interesting
question in other words given a video
given a video object
how would i simply get the conversion
for that video object
from
frames to times although you're pretty
much claiming that times is it
yeah i mean we do support frames but it
has this quantity
frame what i'm saying
yeah sandra is asking is there a video
frame select
is that something like the extract
function
with a criteria
we have video extra video extra
i don't remember anymore video extra
frame extract
no
oh gosh so it is okay right because it
returns frames
but it doesn't have a criteria the
second argument there could very well be
a criteria as opposed to a time
yes reasonable enough
yeah why not
unless i mean i don't quite understand
so in other words you'd say video
extract frames
and then a thing that says there's a dog
in the picture
you get all the frames of the dog in the
picture now what happens if you want to
get a sub video
of all the frames with a you know a
video which is only
you know i want to see the video only
when it had that rhinoceros in it
how would i do that um video map
should be able to do it oh something i
well we'll have to engineer it somehow
if the function returns
nothing for instance do we want to avoid
injecting new frames into the output
video
yes i think it'll be a nice feature okay
um
okay let's see okay brian is suggesting
allow for function to determine whether
a
frame is in a return set of frames
i don't know how useful that is i think
you can just use our standard list
manipulation functions to find out
whether a literal frame
is in that list you just literally are
saying you know
member queue with frames all right
we're still coming back to this video
position thing that is
to find times that match
a criterion
or intervals that match your criterion
i mean they're basically like events or
when will there be a time that matches
the criteria i mean there's a dog
okay there isn't going to be a dog for
one frame or if there is it's some kind
of subliminal advertising dog or
something
you know what i'm saying i mean it's not
a one true story yeah that's true
actually what do we do could be like
corrupted frames
that happen only you know one frame at a
time
no but what do we do now let's say that
you get um
a hundred frames of dogs would we return
hundreds of times yeah a hundred times
seems kind of useless
um
that can be very long that could be very
long
that's again i don't think that's useful
i think it's more useful to do this
intervals thing
sure position could be the first of the
intervals mean of the intervals we could
extract
you know if if or or basically sample
the intervals
if necessary okay so then video
intervals
um
video interval seems more reasonable and
and what it does then
is it says then you are specifying what
you want
you know what part of the interval you
want to return
or you want to return the interval so to
speak
yeah i think if we call it something
intervals it should be intervals and
then it's user's responsibility to get
the first or mean
how by mapping first or mean over it
yeah
fair enough okay so now video intervals
so
so and recall we have
audio intervals which does exactly that
gives you time intervals where something
is happening
well that's a good pattern isn't it we
don't have audio position do we
no but that's even a
much less useful thing because you're
not sampled by sex where you're going to
go
no um look i think video intervals is
the right thing
okay and criterion
fine
that's not silly minimum duration there
well actually i don't know whether that
makes sense that probably doesn't make
sense for video
um and i would even argue that that
might be
happening more happily an option in the
audio intervals case okay
um i see this
this is a good idea i mean that's a um
like for example you might want to pick
up things that are photographic rather
than being
you know credits or something yep
okay so video intervals it would be and
then that would return
intervals here is actually given as as
pairs like this
and these are scalars assumed to be
seconds in seconds when passed to
something else
but i i think both audio intervals and
video intervals could return quantities
or quantity a decision
right yeah
whatever these other functions eat i
mean probably a quantity array makes the
most sense
yep
does it work to say first slash at
quantity array
you better check those things work okay
that's not obvious to me
and if not should it still be a list of
quantities you think
i would just do it in seconds if this
thing is mostly for
machine consumption i wouldn't worry
about it okay
i mean i don't know and and i just don't
think
um
audio position should have the interval
time interval
yeah we already have audio intervals
right so audio intervals of of the bird
will give the audio intervals at which a
bird is heard
yeah i agree with these people who are
saying that the time intervals are the
right thing
and then so long as it works you know
how can i take can i take that pair
and how do i extract how do i get the
sub video
that is that that thing video training
i see so i literally just feed that in
so if i say
video trim video comma hash
map it over this i'll get all the sub
videos yes
that's not bad
okay all right what's next
audio apply what the heck is that
say that you have let's say that you've
done an animation
but you want to add audio to it yeah but
you want to change the audio
that's what it does that's a horrible
name for that
i tend to agree i started something like
because
video audio math well yeah i know i i
think it's got to mention video because
otherwise it's just like like why i mean
that it makes it
seem like it's going to be an audio
function yeah
um and it yeah and in fact because of
this name
we thought okay audio apply could also
work on audio but it is going to be the
same as
the function working on the audio
directly
rather than going through audio apply
right so what what let's understand what
this is
this says um
you know naively video ad audio
um
no that's like video combined where you
can combine video and audio tracks
or a video that has an audio track with
yet another audio track
is it set the audio track of a video
it's process about
an audio track of a video why is it
processing what is it processing
it's it's a video object that already
has an audio track oh sorry i got
confused
stephen it's my fault i confused you i
didn't mean to i i
misremembered
wait a minute apply an audio function to
a specified audio track so
plan
let's take the naive thing okay so
roger's thing
okay so roger's case where i've got a a
a dancing llama and i want to add music
to it
that's gonna be video combined
video come audio i see okay
what if i want to make something where
the music
you know is undulating to the llama
so to speak where the music is in in the
rhythm is determined by the llama
i would go with something like video map
list and then get an audio
out first and then video combined
all right so what is this function this
absolutely incomprehensible function
there is a good illustration there i
guess for this one
so the audio track exists you want to
normalize it
amplify it um time stretch it or
something else
i see i see so why is this not how would
you just do that if it was just an audio
function
it was just a piece of audio what would
you do you would just apply the function
say audio time stretch to the audio
why not just do that to the video why
don't you have all the audio functions
just work on videos
i don't see why that wouldn't work
like that i guess again it's this
track selection business we have to add
audio track selection to all of the
audio functions which doesn't make sense
for
audio objects anyway then how do you
extract okay this is why
i was trying to convince you a while ago
and you weren't paying attention that
having a rapper a symbolic rapper
that represents something like a
selected part of a video
or a track on a video would be useful
but
but the video object is gonna be take
the video object is gonna be that
wrapper
but then when you specify audio tracks
one you're basically ignoring all of the
other tracks
i know that i know that but i'm saying
if but that's why i was saying to you if
you had something
which said audio track select
audio track selection here
outside the video commas five
that is merely representing well i admit
this is a little bit hokey
that doesn't really work what what comes
out still the five-track audio
no no no no no the whole one the whole
thing is what you want obviously
yeah okay hold on hold on so what you're
saying is the
alternatives are the following
um
yeah brian is suggesting um
video map audio yeah it's kind of weird
i think the most natural thing is this
because the the most
natural thing is that there's one audio
track right
not necessarily the video tracks we have
very few samples we have seen very few
real world samples that have
multiple video tracks but with multiple
audio tracks it's like different
languages i know but it's not the most
common case
i agree audio typical video that i
record on my phone
is one track right
so i think for the atypical case we'll
just
do a video combine afterwards
if if needed no but here's the thing we
can still achieve what steven is
pointing out there
if you do video comma video selection
one then you have have it selected
yes and then you do the audio function
so even though the audio functions don't
have all those video selection options
or audio
track selection and stuff there is a
there is a
for the eight typical case what's what's
what is the atypical case how do you do
it again
let's say that you you have let's say
you have two audio tracks to you
okay now in order for it to process you
need to have one selected no no i know
that so what was
just what was the code that you were
saying video video itself the video
wrapper itself video
of the video comma audio selection audio
track selection
and that returns a video with a new
selection set
and then you do the audio time stretch
or whatever on this
yes yes and then and how do you get back
the other
um the other video track audio tracks
rather
how do you re how do you re-put in the
other audio tracks that you didn't want
changed
would you not but we would have to
take this one out as well from the
audience but from what
what is semantics here does this mean
a video oh wait a minute does it does
this produce a video or does it produce
an audio
i think that we wanted it to produce a
video that's what's what audio
we wanted to produce a video the issue
is does this audio track selection arrow
one
it represents a video where you're only
playing the track one audio
correct yeah correct but we also want
almost all functions to be sort of
applied to the one
selection because if the minute you
start multi-selection you get
weird look i think the right thing to do
here is the following
i think the right thing to do is to add
to the audio functions
and audio track selection okay which
most of the time won't do anything
because audio has a one
track story how do you apply
when you have quadraphonic audio how do
you apply to just one what
are those things called those are
channels right of audio yeah correct
and how do you do the analogous thing
with different channels if i want to
time stretch just one channel
how do i do that um are you a channel
separate
and then audio channel combined we
cannot map directly just to one channel
well maybe there's maybe there's an
analogy here
for this rather obscure case look
they're two alternatives
either you break the audio apart you do
that kind of processing you recombine
you put it back in the video
always support audio track selection
in these various audio functions which i
think will be my preference
you know we just documented when applied
to a video this
selects which track it will be applied
to
ah maybe not
look the other possibility is you simply
extract the appropriate
okay if you're applying so video map
applies an operation
to a video frame by frame
right yes
and then
okay
look audio track
um
you know audio track apply would be
better than audio apply
sandra is asking why not an option to a
certain channel and by default do it on
all channels
but we're not talking channels we're
talking tracks here
i think i'd be okay with audio track
apply
i like that better too i think it's hard
to misunderstand that
is it apply though it is because you're
giving it functions like all your time
stretch you you apply that function to
the
all right okay yeah okay all right fine
all right audio track apply it is okay
what's next
anything else um i guess that's it from
the video list
okay what else is there
here
i think one thing you bypass the random
image linear gradient image and so forth
in the image section
we are adding it type argument
maybe you look at them let's say image
subsection
just want to make sure you've seen that
what is that no i i didn't know that
too specific so far by default we're
creating
uh real images all the time now we're
specifying that
type argument that says it can be a byte
bit 16 or whatever
i mean what is the first argument anyway
here
um the max intensity value one
okay and then what then i can hear say
integer 16 or something
yeah bit 60 don't forget to auto
complete
sure
whatever is that that's 12-1-1 prototype
deals already
and secured bills have it okay okay
seems fine to me okay
okay what else then i guess if
um what else from import export
um pdf new didn't we look at that last
time
i had we have some alternative
suggestions for
a couple of elements that we that's in
under the ota
for the page page results
if you scroll down do you see a
tentative table i'm wondering when you
updated the
um no i think this is you don't have the
updates
i can get the updates hold on but tell
me what the story is though
um you suggested pages
plain text page images and so forth
i would like to suggest page plain text
page images page graphics page formatted
text
so they all start with page and then
continue with the
element name that otherwise gets us the
whole document
data so wait a minute so so
you're saying say that again so you're
saying everything just becomes if it is
a per page deal what is
i don't understand that i mean so so
like plain text or something it would be
page plain text
and then that would give a list of the
plain text by page
is that correct yes that seems right to
me
and then what are some other options for
that uh the formatted text is another
one
we have formatted text which is by
default for the whole document a row of
style text and if it's page formatted
text that becomes a list of formatted
text
i see
those two blue tentative
how can you get images other than page
images yeah
that that's why they don't show up in
the first table the first table are
the results for the whole pdf the second
table
are per page elements
so i'm sorry which table so it says
forwarded text
the the blue the two tentative tables
are the replacement
for the one format to text yes i like
this this is good
okay i'm good with this
okay anything else
um brief discussion about flv you
suggest that we don't obsolete it
and add import there is a small
technical issue we are just going to not
obsolete it 12
2 and then um
add import probably next version but i
just wanted to point that out okay what
happened to our xls
and csv import and export stuff has that
is that
has that had a speed update not yet in
12.2
xls is fast no problem with that
yeah xls is fast csv can be faster
yes and so it will hit it for 12 to
plus whatever that next version is okay
sounds good all right nothing else no
okay looking really nice um all right
does this mean that you are
done with your design reviews for twelve
two or not
i guess it'll work out
yeah roger i expected us to have one
catch-up review
we wanted to do this one early because
there were things we thought that you
might have big opinions about
and okay fine i think we we resolved
this one yep yeah
and so there might be a small catch-up
review but nothing big okay that's just
fine
hey what's what's coming next roger what
other what reviews are
we are pd modeling tomorrow um
and then i think we're hitting almost
all the others
are not getting quite ready enough until
pretty much first week of september
or so first second when do we see
geospatial statistics and things
um that's in that time frame as well
okay hey brian on our live stream is
asking what does text mean as far as
ascii utf-8 etc it doesn't matter
because it's coming into awesome
language
so it's just our strings
right so you don't you don't care about
what that what that underlying encoding
is it's going straight from whatever the
pdf encoding is
to our meaningful internal encoding
which you can think of as unicode but
it doesn't really matter um
okay sounds good well thanks to
everybody
thanks to you guys thanks durability on
the live stream lots of very useful
comments
uh tune in tomorrow for we have two
three live streams tomorrow but about
different topics we have pde modeling
we have design for interactive graphics
and then we have a brainstorming meeting
about experimental tests of our physics
models we're a different kind of thing
um all right thanks a lot guys
see you later